- Well, I heard that you
have a classic New York story
about a fake ID.
This is sad, I think.
- Yeah, it's sad.
- I think someone told me that.
- Yeah, it's a sad story.
- Okay.
- Okay, I was-
I mean, when I was a teenager,
I grew up in Queens, so we
would take the subway into-
I liked to go to Times Square,
which I feel horrible for my
parents now, looking back,
because I would love to go to Times Square
all the time.
- Yeah, it's bright and shiny.
- It's bright and shiny.
So I once went with a
friend to Times Square
and I was walking around
and there was like-
You know, you just hear like
distant voices in the crowd
that's like, "Tattoos,
piercings, fake IDs."
And I turned around and
I was like, "Fake IDs?"
So then the guy was like-
I was really young and stupid
and I was like, "Why not?"
So he was like, okay, but we're gonna-
So this is the plan, we
are gonna go to Roy Rogers,
and like, I have to do some checks.
So like, let's go to Roy Rogers.
We went to Roy Rogers, which was,
if you guys don't know, it
was an old chicken chain.
- I did not.
- You didn't know what Roy Rogers is?
- No, I think there's
like a coliseum in Texas.
Maybe named that.
Or Will Rogers.
That's what it is.
No, I don't know that one.
- Roy Rogers, it's like a chicken-
It's like a chicken fast food place.
So it was very public.
- I like chicken.
Okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
So we went upstairs and
he pointed to a table.
And he was like, you see that guy?
And there was a guy-
He was in a hat with what
looked like a trench coat.
And he was like, that's my associate.
And I was like, okay.
Good to know that you
operated out Roy Rogers.
He then was like, do you
have any bills on you?
Because I have to check that-
I have to make sure that
you're 15-years-old.
You're not a CIA agent.
So I need to get your bills off of you.
So I had a $10 bill on me
and I gave him my $10 bill.
And he was like, okay,
I'm gonna go run this through the machine.
Stay here, my associate's right there.
And so he leaves and
like, 45 minutes goes by.
I have a whole chicken meal, right?
And I keep eyeing his associate.
He's like reading a newspaper,
doing very like, associate
things, you know?
And he didn't come back
for like, 45 minutes.
So I get up and I kind of go
over to the his associate.
And I'm like, excuse me sir, your partner-
I just wanna make sure he's okay
that he didn't hit any road bumps.
And he was like, what
are you talking about?
So he didn't even know that guy.
He just made off with $10.
- I love how sweet you
were at a young age,
I think 'cause I'm the youngest child,
so much crap was pulled on me
that I would've been like BS.
Like, you have such a
different childhood than me
that you believed in the good of people.
- Yeah, I was like,
"Yes, I of course I want
you to have this $10 bill
to check if I'm a CIA agent."
- Yes, I love that!
That's so horrible.
But you got a chicken meal
and you got to meet a
nice man in a trench coat.